ladies and gentlemen please welcome back
dave rubin and please welcome orlando
magic star jonathan isaac
not bad
all right man standing ovation before
you did anything
pretty good makes me feel welcome though
so appreciate it yeah
i think they were just trying to measure
up i guess the the real question get
everybody tall
6 11. that's the answer to the question
i know everyone's thinking the same
thing 6 11.
uh i'm gonna let jonathan do most of the
talking here but i do have to say that
my true dream in life was to be an nba
player
he was telling me he's pretty good too
well what was the funny part of that
that yeah
now i'm 45 with a torn acl in my left
knee he's got a torn acl in his left
hand repaired
but we'll be back in a couple weeks yeah
uh but your story is just
really freaking unbelievable and it's so
consistent with everything we've been
talking about at this conference of of
people standing up for what they believe
in and taking unpopular positions in
this very weird time
so maybe first before we get into some
of that stuff could you just tell people
a little bit just about your history and
just what got you to the nba and then
we'll unpack the rest of the stuff
okay so uh hi everybody uh i would say
my history i was born in bronx new york
i have uh
i have four brothers and one sister
i moved from new york to florida when i
was 10 with my with my mom my brothers
and my sister and
over the course of time just fell in
love with basketball and over time and
playing i went to florida state for a
year so shout out to whoever said
go knows
and then i found myself in the league
the sixth pick
um i had my i don't know how many of you
are any in the room are christians but i
have my coming to christ moment while i
was a rookie in the nba
and
and and that has been my i guess just
like guiding guiding force um and
figuring out what it is that i'm gonna
do and trying to my best to become who
god has called me to be uh but i think
that what what has gotten me on this
stage is
both my love for
uh you know philosophy and thought and
and and
conversations and being able to talk to
people from you know
completely different backgrounds i i
think it's it's clear that i'm really
not supposed to be here uh based on
based on what i look like but um i'm
glad to be here i'm thankful for the
invite and i'm glad to be able to talk
to everybody that's here
and uh
yeah so so those two things have kind of
been my navigation um i fell in love
with uh jordan peterson and you and a
lot of the people who are just
constantly talking not necessarily about
the left first the right but the ideals
that you know that pin our country um
as it is and i think those a lot of
those ideals are the the spirit of
christ um
and so uh yeah so it's led me to you
know being the only one to stand for the
national anthem and now with this
vaccine mess
and now i'm at the
national conservatism
talking to dave rubin so i'm glad to be
here thank you so much
[Applause]
i like how he couldn't even say it with
a straight face you know it's like
wait let's talk a little bit more about
standing for the national anthem because
we're going to get into the the covid
stuff but that in and of itself that was
that was la that was when you guys were
in the bubble yeah that was august of
last year and and what was that like
like did you have to think beforehand
okay i'm gonna do the unpopular thing
did you know what everyone else was
gonna do were guys talking about it it
was crazy uh so you know right around
the time obviously looking at everything
that was happening in the country with
george floyd and knowing that with black
lives matter there was going to be some
type of
demonstration or you know the people who
were protesting or in the streets or
whatever but when it came to the league
you know a lot of guys got together in
the teams and everybody and had decided
that what they wanted to do was kneel um
and kind of from that onset i was
already like
i don't think that that is me um
because of you know my understanding for
myself that
wearing a t-shirt or kneeling for the
national anthem is not
does not go hand in hand with supporting
black lives and when i've looked at my
life
and how it's been supported by the
gospel and by christ i was saying
i don't sit high enough to look down on
any group of people or anybody for what
happened in that specific situation and
um didn't feel it was my right to to to
do that and it wasn't it wasn't in
protest to anybody's protest i respect
everybody that decided to kneel but for
me it wasn't the right thing for me to
do and uh yeah
you know it's kind of funny it's like
you're sort of laughing at being at the
national conservatives
and yet and yet it's very obvious in
five minutes while you're here right
like you got it you got it
what kind of blowback did you get blow
back from the players were people were
players upset with you was the was the
league upset with you i mean we saw what
the media kind of did yeah i mean i had
conversations and and that's ultimately
what i set out to do um i knew that
being able to talk to people in my
desire to have conversations and sit
down and talk about you know my
reasoning and saying that christ is the
answer for the problems that we see in
the world and until we can humble
ourselves and reckon with that we won't
see real change um at a heart level of
individual people and so i believed that
for myself and i was like i'm ready to
talk to people about it so i had a lot
of conversations with you know different
guys in the league um and was able to
talk to different people but you know
the blow back from the media and
everything and even you know being here
at the at the conference again i i i
know that it's coming but um i i don't
think that
uh
you know that that not coming i think i
think not coming owes a greater price
than coming they're not coming and so uh
yeah and
but but what i what i will say is that
the the outpouring of support and love
um from people that thought this that
that thought the same as me um you know
have who have been supported by the
gospel in their own lives or people who
just had their own ideal or respect for
the flag of the country um in any degree
uh you know agreed and supported it and
it was a lot more positive than negative
and so um i was grateful for that yeah
and i know that you you step into these
things
honestly and earnestly because when i
messaged you we had started messaging
over the last couple of weeks and when i
said i'm going to be in orlando and you
know will you will you come to the
national conservatism conference you
were like yeah i'll come like why not
why wouldn't i come and and here we are
so what really put you on the map after
that separate from basketball was this
incredible press conference that you did
this is about what about two months ago
now or so
where you started talking about why you
chose not to be vaccinated and i'm sure
most of the people have seen it here but
you gave as what as i said on my show
what i thought was the most thoughtful
coherent
honest answer related to personal choice
and all that stuff so can you kind of
sum up
what you what you said and actually how
did that even come to pass that that you
had to talk about it yeah so i just to
take you guys back the night before i'm
like i'm sitting in my bathroom and i'm
like what am i going to say
because uh
and how it started was you know with
decided not to get the vaccine for the
reasons that i had laid out you know um
i've had covert already
i think the science continues to come
out that you know our reaction to
natural infection is robust and
long-lasting in terms of immunity uh i'm
young i'm healthy uh you know the
vaccine not stopping infection or
transmission uh and just the the opening
yourself up to the possibility of having
adverse reaction to the vaccine and then
that on the other side of that all of
the hysteria and the craziness around
not allowing people to have free choice
um and just feeling like people are just
beating people up over this thing that
should be everybody's free choice and
the media's handling of it all and so
what happened was that sunday
a couple days before that sunday i had a
a
journalist called me from the rolling
stone
and he's like you know just you know
good good faith and just like oh you
know i just want to get your ideas about
the vaccine and how you feel about it
i'm like sure talking to him and then
the story drops on sunday the day before
the press conference and it's like
jonathan isaac came to his vaccination
status by watching donald trump and and
and
and
and studying black history and i was
like
i was like no and uh yes and i was like
okay i have this
opportunity um on monday to kind of
clear the air and share what i really
feel what i really think and i'm sitting
in my bathroom like okay what am i gonna
say i'm like praying god give me the
words to say and but i didn't expect all
of this to come out of it so i'm glad
that i didn't know that this was gonna
come out because i would have been way
more nervous but
i was able to just get up and kind and
just and just share from my heart i
think i think you know even a lot of
people in here and you is just it is a
sincere
desire to move forward as a people as a
country and to help as many people as
possible
and so that that's why i'm here and
that's what i aim to do yeah
did you secretly get support from some
other players because i'm guessing
there's got to be a lot of players that
did not want to do this and certainly
wouldn't take the public position but
maybe privately we're reaching out to
you yeah and respect to those guys um
you know even even take lebron with what
he said um you know he said that he did
his own research and him and his family
got vaccinated but he felt that it was
everybody's um decision to do that for
themselves draymond green bradley b all
these other guys so
shout out to them for taking that stance
and i think a lot of other guys in the
league feel that way because we have the
pa that says that you know the league
can't mandate the vaccine for us so that
was a decision on the player's part to
say even though i'm vaccinated i don't
think it should be mandated for the
other players so you know shout out to
the guys in the league for that yeah and
thankfully you're here in florida here
in orlando specifically
because you know kyrie in brooklyn is in
a whole different situation where where
you know new york was going to do
certain things and then the nets jumped
on top of it so you're you're also
doubly sort of blessed to be here in
florida i guess it's not an accident
absolutely a blessing i'm glad to be in
florida with everything that we have
going on um and yeah it's it's
unfortunate for the kyrie situation and
you know i just feel like he has a great
you know he gets a great deal of respect
for me for the courage that it takes to
not only say no but to to forego money
and everything that he's doing and um he
really does care about the people who
are losing jobs and and feeling like
they don't have a place to turn in this
whole matter so let's talk a little bit
more about
philosophy
and religion and belief because i know
that's that's really your thing and when
when i message you i saw you followed me
and i was like oh man nba players
following me this is great like i'm
going to talk about basketball and then
immediately you wanted to talk about
jordan peterson and i was like all right
we can we can do that too
you know
we could do that too um
but you've really thought seriously i
mean even just in the five minutes we
chatted back there you've thought
seriously about the issues that this
conference is about about belief and
government and and how we go about
living our best lives and all these
things were you always a believer was
this something you were taught very
young did you come to this later in life
well i i grew up christian my my dad was
we were in church every day it felt like
um learning
like
like memorizing whole songs and all that
stuff um but as i as i got into
basketball kind of just took over and i
found my identity in basketball in the
game and if i was playing well i was up
if i was playing bad i was down and i
found that that was you know my form of
of wanting to be loved um to a to a
degree and trying to find it in all the
wrong places but what i found in in
christ in in coming to the league and
pretty much being able to experience
everything that i thought i wanted um
that his love for me has transcended the
love of people in a real like tangible
way in my life and wrestling with his
unconditional love has gotten me to the
place that i am today and helped me to
be a better person and a better man um
and then when it comes to you know the
philosophy part i've always felt like
i've been a thinker you know people used
to tell me like you always like you
don't talk you just think and observe
and i've always been somebody that tries
to dissect what's going on like if two
people are fighting i'm like okay what
happened here and what happened here i'm
like i'm trying to get to the bottom of
it and figure out what was the what was
the trigger or what in their life said
that but whatever and so and so uh when
this whole thing broke with jordan
peterson um and and looking into the
story of obviously like the bill c-16
and toronto and all that stuff and i'm
like
he doesn't strike me
as a white supremacist
and and and
and and
so and so being a being able to just
dissect it all and have those
conversations and understand that a lot
of that stuff was coming from an
emotional you know people in in in that
situation that people who have been
influenced in a certain direction i just
dove into his lectures and everything
that he's talked about and and then
through through him found drew with the
whole tour and and uh you know a bunch
of the other people who are here that
have spoken and talked and all that
stuff i just started to get into it and
just and just learn just like not again
not from a right-left perspective or a
conservative or liberal perspective but
from just a strictly you know
philosophical perspective about how we
as people go about living together and
create what are the best grounds to
create a free society for people to to
navigate and to grow and be free and
then also pair that with supporting
people who you know to a degree with our
history and um you know things that have
happened socially and economically bring
support to people but it's just about
the best way to go about doing it um and
i think that the more we're able to talk
about it and be honest about the things
that we feel and be able to come to a
national conservative conference and and
be black and talk about it and go to
other places
it'll ultimately be far good
man i feel bad for jd vance because he
could have given the keynote tonight huh
i don't i definitely don't need to be
here right now um
well with all that in mind what do you
think maybe sort of politically you saw
some of the names of the people that are
here these are heavy hitters in the
political world people that are trying
to make some sense in the madness what
do you think some of us could be doing
better
i i think that during this time um okay
i'll say this so so
the i saw a video of like bill bill
mayor yeah
talking and um you know i think i
understand where he where he falls
politically but i heard him talking
about the vaccine i'm like this is
a common sense position dude that that
probably doesn't agree politically with
a lot of the people in the room and i'm
like
with everything that's going on and
people feel like they're being abandoned
by common sense because he's like this
doesn't make sense natural immunity is
real and i'm like yo i agree with you
but um
being able to reach those people um in a
way that kind of leaves the
i would say leaves the conservative not
not ideals and not space but leaves the
way that conservatism has been
branded um by people and being able to
reach people that just care about
working and providing for those families
and and being able to reach them in a
real way with their ideas and and being
able to lay out how this thing is going
to work to move the country in a better
position um and so i think that during
this time there are a lot of people who
have common sense that are saying what's
happening is crazy um and there's a lot
of things that are going on that aren't
even though they're afraid to be in the
best interest of people um when you
dissect them you know down to the you
know each personal level it doesn't and
so being able to reach those people in a
real way i think is how we move forward
you know i hate to do the the identity
politics version of this but since
identity politics has been such a theme
here do you think conservatives or
whatever this new thing that's sort of
developing right now can do more with
the black community is there is there a
way to do it that is that is honest and
not pandering and is right and healing
and any of that stuff do you think i
mean i think absolutely i think
i think i think it's like double-sided
it's it's can we
promote
freedom and personal choice and and
giving people the tools to become all
that they can be in this system of
capitalism and entrepreneurship and all
that
while honoring and respecting the
history of our country and um you know
the social and economical
you know problems that have you know
happened to the black community can we
do both and can there be a clear message
that
reaches the black community where you
know they're like you know take
take uh
to i mean take me for example like being
able to play basketball and make money
and somebody that's about to go out and
work and and become you know who i am
today that's great but not everybody is
in that position so can you at the same
time give me the freedom to be a
basketball player and go out and make
money and be great but at the same time
honor that somebody else that looks like
me isn't in that same place to do so and
provide support not cater to or baby or
pacify but
provide support in a real way and being
able to cut through a lot of the
language and the
white supremacists and the all that
stuff that's been thrown um i don't
think any of you are white supremacists
in here but
you do know that you'll be a white
supremacist by the time the night is
through that's how that's how it works
but look i i i think i i think that only
shows um that it doesn't mean anything
um and it takes away
and it it takes it takes away from the
word and what it really means and how
terrible that thing is um to call
everybody that so i i
i think that there is there is a way to
articulate what i just said to people of
color and minorities in a way that they
can jump on board as they look around
and see that it's not really somebody
who who may
profess that they have their best
interest interests at heart but don't
and so if if the message is able to be
tailored and you know handled the right
way i think there is a way forward
my last question since we're running out
of time here we want to be respectful of
everybody
what else is on your mind i mean that
that's really all i got it's like you
strike me as somebody that you will be
here next year giving a talk properly
yourself yeah
i mean really i you weren't here for
these last three days but the things
that you have said in these 20 minutes
have been exactly what this conference
is about trying to figure out where
those differences religious philosophic
political how do we piece that together
to get to something better you nailed it
cool
so what else is on your mind you got the
floor
uh what else is on my mind i i think
that's it i um i i want to
you know when you're talking about like
black people or people that look like me
or are people who are in this space that
don't feel like they have the tools
necessary to stand up for what they
believe in um
and and to me feel you know they have
been influenced in a certain direction
away by the media by all the people that
that are that are at hands to make money
in a certain direction i'm like how can
i
provide the tools that have been
afforded to me through christ and
through just how i've thought and
package it in a way and so this is not
to just the plug but i am working on the
book right now and it's called it's
called why stand um and what it is is it
takes the journey of my life and you
know being a young kid and experiencing
racism at a young age and um being
somebody that at a time would not be on
this stage or stand up for what he
believed in but finding my courage
finding my strength and confidence in
christ to then step out and be the only
one to do something and so kind of
packaging that in a way to give people
the tools and the confidence and the
courage
to step out and stand for what they
believe in
you know it's funny i'm listening to you
and i'm looking at you and i'm going man
i wish i could do
what you do for a living and look how
easily you just did what i do for a
living
that
that is messed up
uh
well i'll end with with one last thing
which is uh you know during my speech
earlier this morning i said you know
we'll see what happens sort of with the
republicans
is it going to be trump is it going to
be decent this could be somebody else
they all got various rounds of applause
but i'm pretty sure
it could be jonathan isaac everybody i'm
going to get out of the way give this
man a round of applause
thanks man
that was awesome
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell